ben le boss égratignures aux sports tout
simplement parce que nous sommes
maladroit nous nous faisons tous des
petits bobos mais pourquoi notre peau
marque-t-elle ainsi et quels sont les
remèdes les plus efficaces nos experts
vous disent tout
tous les mercredis les jeunes joueurs de
rugby de châtillon et d'issy les
moulineaux en banlieue parisienne
s'entraînent ensemble et les contacts
sont parfois énergique
chez les enfants qu'on va parler plutôt
de petits bobos alors ça peut être
éventuellement quelques petits hématomes
et tiges contact des petites bosses mais
ça c'est pas plus que dans la cour de
l'école
mais les plaquages
et à la fin de l'entraînement ils ont
tous
il ya plus de bleu vu que le contact
parfois bah
voilà ça fait des bleus quoi j'ai des
blancs que au niveau des abdos souvent
et au niveau des dépôts est
un bleu en langage médical c'est une
ecchymose mais comment se forme tél
au cours de ce traumatisme de ce coup un
petit vaisseau un capillaires ou une
veine une petite artère peut être abîmée
et donc la sacem sous la peau et des
petits vaisseaux nous en avons beaucoup
dans un corps humain il y à peu près
cent mille kilomètres de vaisseau
cent mille kilomètres cela représente
deux fois et demi le tour de la terre à
l'intérieur de ce gigantesque réseau
circulent notre sens il est composé d'un
liquide le plasma dans lequel on trouve
trois types de cellules les globules
blancs les globules rouges et les
plaquettes
si un vaisseau est endommagée lors d'un
choc ces plaquettes réagissent
immédiatement aux pros un sauna est
envoyé et les plaquettes viennent en
fait ce collées les unes aux autres elle
arrête le saignement elles font comme un
pansement en fait soins capillaires ou
sur la veine une ecchymose c'est donc un
amas de sang sous la peau mais pourquoi
est-elle bleus alors que notre sens et
rouge
ils sont rouges bien rouge sous le sens
qui est chargé l'oxygène quand il sort
des poules dans les artères mais dans
les veines de son est plutôt d'une
couleur double jeu là c'est donc c'est
pour ça qu'au départ c'est bleu c'est
donc en bleu que se colore la peau mais
ça ne dure pas très longtemps car ni
globules blancs entre alors en action et
ils vont transformer la couleur de notre
équipe aux lorsque le temps passe et
bien les nettoyeurs de notre corps que
sont les globules blancs viennent couper
les limes login qui se situe juste sous
la peau et va effectivement modifié sa
couleur l'hémoglobine c'est le pigment
qui donne aux sans sa couleur rouge ou
bleu sous l'action des globules blancs
qui vont la dgrad et petit à petit elle
va virer au vert et enfin au jaune
voilà pourquoi à la surface de la peau
c'est un véritable arc en ciel pendant
15 jours environ
mais on dit souvent que certaines
personnes ont une peau qui marquent plus
que d'autres est ce vrai en fait la
nature fait que les personnes ont des
capillaires besoin fragiles ou une peau
plus ou moins fines et de ce fait c'est
vrai que les enfants et les personnes
âgées ont une peau plus fine et donc
marque plus mais il n'ya pas que les
bleus regardez certains de nos rugbymen
ont aussi des casques ça protège jeune
qui veut les bosses au niveau de la tête
mais qu'est ce qui différencie une bosse
d'un bleu il n'y a pas en fait
d'hémorragie à proprement parler mais
une réaction inflammatoire pure et bien
à ce moment là c'est plutôt du liquide
qui va sortir des vaisseaux c'est le
plasma et le plasma est incolore les
boss se produit uniquement aux endroits
où la peau est quasiment collé à l'os
comme par exemple sur la tête
ça fait mal mais ça ne devient bleu
qu'en cas de chocs extrêmes
dans notre quotidien les spécialistes
des bosses et des bleus ce sont les
enfants emmanuel deux ans est un petit
garçon dégourdi qui donne parfois de
sacrées frayeurs à sa mère pegi
ça fait bobo quand il était petit on a
eu droit à quelques bleus quelques
bosses à cet endroit là ici dans les
points parce qu'effectivement bas canton
quand on veut se rapprocher de la table
quand on veut faire l'acrobatie c'est
plutôt le front qui cogne
peggy a beau s'être équipé cela ne
suffit pas toujours alors comment faire
pour soigner les bosses où les bleus
alors en cas de bleu ou de bosses on a
tous le titre up de premiers secours
savoir bas le gel en tout cas qu'il soit
quand même très très bien
l'arnica une plante des montagnes que
nous connaissons tous et elle aussi
efficace qu'on le dit
alors ni casque une vieille croyance
mais sur le plan scientifique l'arnica
n'a jamais montré la moindre preuve
d'efficacité en revanche pour notre
spécialiste le champion toutes
catégories pour soigner les bobos c'est
la fameuse poche de glace
lorsque je mets du froid sur une bosse
en fait les vaisseaux vont se fermer ce
qu'on stricte et comme on dit et à ce
moment là et bien sûr et bien le liquide
va moins sortir et comme le liquide va
moins sortir la bosse pas moins être
importante et va disparaître beaucoup
plus rapidement et l'accès aux du froid
est exactement la même pour les bleus
enfin le froid est un excellent anti
douleur ça envoie au cerveau à notre
signal qui trompe un peu le cerveau le
sarrau étant préoccupés à identifier le
changement de température qui s'effectue
au niveau du traumatisme la douleur
ressentie est moins forte autres bobos
de notre quotidien les égratignures
comment la peau réagit-elle à ses
blessures superficielles
direction clamart sur leur skate florian
et thomas sont impressionnants et côté
égratignures ils sont rodés
face à pau elle frôle les sols sa brune
et donc ça ouvre mais c'est ouvert le
coup les genoux
ça m'arrive assez souvent et nous
comptons beaucoup sur le béton et ça
frotte donc voilà ça saigne soir
notre peau est composé de trois couches
l'épiderme le derme et l'hypoderme dans
une égratignure c'est l'épiderme qui est
concerné ça va saigner pendant quelques
temps quelques minutes ensuite les
plaquettes donc un long travail pour
arrêter l'hémorragie souvenez-vous comme
pour nos bleus les plaquettes réagissent
immédiatement stoppant le saignement
mais quand on a une égratignure que
faut-il faire
la première chose à faire c'est de se
laver les mains soi même d'abord parce
que si l'on ne pense pas à se laver les
mains et qu'on s'occupe de l'appeler
vient on amène les germes que l'on a
tous sur nos mains au quotidien et puis
ensuite eh bien on va simplement
nettoyer à l'eau et oui l'eau courante
permet d'éliminer à elle seule les trois
quarts des microbes présents sur notre
peau par précaution faut-il désinfecter
à l'alcool eh bien non l'alcool n'est
pas plus efficace tout particulier en
mêlant les alcools sang de type 90 et en
plus ça pique à l'oxygène et alors là
encore il n'y a pas beaucoup de preuves
scientifiques en la matière ce n'est pas
un bon antiseptique donc aujourd'hui il
n'est pas à utiliser pour les pl est
simple le mieux est un simple spray
antiseptique incolore et indolore
ensuite il faut protéger la plaie avec
un pansement le temps qu'une croûte
apparaissent c'est le processus normal
de cicatrisation
connaissez la coupe ce qu'on fait à ne
pas la gratter de la ne pas essayer
d'atouts prix de l'enlever plus
rapidement que elle ne le voudrait de
manière spontanée parce que eh bien on
risque de nouveau à reproduire une
petite plaie qui va elle de nouveau
rentrer dans le cycle est retardé la
cicatrisation
bleus boss égratignures ces bobos du
quotidien n'ont désormais plus de secret
pour vous pour vous soulager il ya des
réflexes à avoir mais c'est avant tout
votre corps qui seraient pas tout seul
[Musique]